okay i would like to show you a really
cool procedural drawing that you could
do yourself straight away right now it's
called a hitomizati stitch pattern it's
a way of visibly mending clothes
and usually they are very rigid in their
pattern but since we're mathematicians
we can play around with some
probabilities and see what we can do do
you want to give me some ones and zeros
what do you want me to do to say some
numbers so i'm i actually love this
different ways of finding ones and zeros
so why don't you give me a phrase and
we'll do the vowels ones and the
consonants zeros may the force be with
you
okay
may
the
force be
with you
okay so as long as they're you oh
all right didn't come here to spell
so as long as you've got two different
states you can do this so it can be ones
and zeros vowels and consonants odds and
evens like play around with it find a
good way that you want to decide if you
are starting on or off so we're doing
vowels and we're going to start off
consonants we're going to start on and
what i mean by that is this stitching so
m consonant please so we're going to
start on which means right from the
get-go i'm going to put a stitch there
this one put one here miss one put one
here this one put one here okay and just
as if you were stitching clothes we're
gonna stitch
along the way
okay
next one
a is a vowel so we're starting off so
i'm gonna miss one to start with it's
just one phase over so miss one and then
we can put my stitch here
here and here okay and i'm going to
continue on why vowel or consonant it's
a consonant
and that likes to pretend it's a vowel
so
[Music]
now we have a nice little wave going
across the way and we need our stitches
going vertical um but we just use pi for
that we'll just use the digits of pi
odds and evens
i like finding fun ways of deciding what
you're gonna do okay so go three
one
four one five nine
two
six
three
five
eight
nine now you're just shutting off
three point one four one five nine two
six five two five eight nine seven nine
three two three three two three eight
four six two six
four
three three eight three
two seven nine five oh done zero two
eight four one nine
could be making enough but i wouldn't
now
um so same thing again but we're gonna
do odds we'll start off evens will start
on and we'll go down the way
[Music]
[Music]
oh
yeah it's a nice picture um
it's fun to procedurally generate things
so this came from may the force be with
you and pie it's a cool way to add
randomness into your drawing the cool
thing you can do with this is you can
then go and color it in as far as i've
found they're always too colorable which
makes sense to me but i don't know if
there's a proof out there but you can
always color in with just two colors
but i think we can do a little bit
better i think we can investigate this
further
so one thing to think about in maths
when you learn something new this is now
some knowledge that you have is think
how could i change this um what are the
limits what could i do with this
immediately i thought that's really nice
like i like how it looks on the square
grid but i wonder what it would look
like on an iso grid so where you've got
your 30 or 60 degrees so i put it onto
an iso grid and then i wondered
what would the differences be if
you changed how random it was so pi
probably normal um probably got an even
distribution of odds and even numbers
may the force be with you that's a bit
random but what if we did something like
saw um maybe a 10 chance of putting down
a one and then a 20 chance of putting
down a one and so on what do you think
you would see happening in the pattern
would there be anything to see is it
totally random if it was completely zero
percent chance of getting a one so it's
just all zeroes you're all starting in
the off state what do you think's gonna
happen
well you'll just get like
big straight lines and shoots that you
could fall down and things like that
yeah it looks a lot more rigid so i mean
i've switched it up onto the iso paper
just so that we can play around with it
always always have fun with your maths
play around with it enjoy it and let's
see what this looks like okay so if you
are always starting in your off state
and then we'd have to do it in this
direction here
and one more direction to go
this way oh three now yeah uh-huh and
you know always you can just add another
dimension to things
[Music]
okay totally rigid you can see a pattern
going on there and that is the
probability of starting in the on
position is zero and the probability of
starting in the off position is one and
then you just introduce more and more
randomness to it so my question is once
we get to the probability of the on
position being 0.9 do you think that's
going to be incredibly random less
random what do you think is going to
happen there intuitively you'd think it
just becomes a little bit less random
but i've also made enough of these
videos to know that introducing just a
little bit of change can make things go
chaotic on me so yes it's not chaotic i
do love when chaotic things happen but
this is not chaotic probability of
starting on
we're going to go with 0.1 probably
starting off is 0.9
now i need to randomly generate these
okay cool and now
i'll make this into a picture
[Music]
okay
so this is what it looks like now that
we've got the probability of starting in
the on position
0.1 so there's a 1 in 10 chance of
starting in the on position it came up a
little bit more than one one in ten but
that happens it's still a one in ten
chance that it would have happened what
do i interpret from that it kind of it
looks well what do you think do you
think it looks wildly different same a
couple of times you know obviously it
looks the same down that part and then
it looks like it's gone a bit skewing
yeah aha so you can think of this as
like the baseline pattern this is it
with no randomness and then we've
introduced a little bit of randomness so
you can see there are some similarities
there are some differences i got this
wrong when i made my first prediction
about what was going to happen when i
started playing around with the
randomness of this pattern i thought you
know it starts rigid that makes sense
and then as i get more and more random
it's going to get progressively more
weird looking and chaotic perhaps i was
wrong so
i think that you can get it from what's
going on here but actually the the point
where it becomes most random and least
looking like this is at the 50 50 mark
and then it starts becoming rigid again
but one phase out and that's because if
you are starting in the on position you
know with a 0.1 percentage 0.1
probability
then your off position is 0.9 when you
get to 0.9 they've just flipped over so
you're in essence doing the same thing
you've got the same probability going on
again at 0.9 so
do you want to see what 0.5 would look
like the most random one and then we'll
have a look at the probability switched
over
and this is where the most hectic
pattern happens
okay
[Music]
yep it's pretty pretty hectic looking
it's
pretty unrecognizable from the first one
nice pattern
a little bit more random and then you
can see it's kind of losing losing the
plot but
it's a nice way to say that it is
getting hectic in here and then it gets
progressively more rigid again and goes
back into another pattern okay so now
the probability of starting on
is gonna be zero we're not going to
start on at all and the probability of
starting off
certainty that is happening so that's
the mirror of that one yeah
it kind of looks like it just moves over
a wee bit
[Music]
starting on each time
and
ready for the massive anti-chromatic
surprise that it did not in fact become
more and more random it got more random
up to 0.5 and then it became less random
again and it looks exactly the same it
just moved over a wee bit you should
always just think what can you change
what can you play around with make a
prediction see if you want like you know
if you want to guess what's happening or
you could just see what happens to play
around with things and see what happens
so this is used by people who are like
sewing and stitching things yeah uh-huh
so if you like if you get a hole in your
pocket or your sock or whatever um you
can stitch it on the front and it looks
really cool who wouldn't want that
stitched on the front of their shirt you
know
[Music]
[Music]
you